welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and now that She-Hulk is complete
it's becoming increasingly clear that
this series like pretty much all of the
phase 4 MCU Disney plus series
experience quite a bit of in-process
retooling behind the scenes which I
gotta get to the bottom of that
retolding this series even poked fun at
with its fourth wall breaking finale and
yes like pretty much every MCU titles
especially those in recent years what we
got from the She-Hulk series is not
exactly what was planned from the outset
alternate episode structure or alternate
character designs alternate endings
re-conceived the effects shots so as we
come to the end of phase four I think we
need to talk about Kevin and Kevin's
original plan for this game breaking
hero because while critics of this show
and of the MCU point to this is some
evidence of the studio having some flops
where I actually think it's a creative
win to still come out of this process
with something so many of us still enjoy
as someone who has written several
screenplays for movies and TV shows
stuff that has never been made and
probably should not get made for me
discussing how the sausage gets made
makes me appreciate the sausage even
more throw it on all my pizzas and for
us here on YouTube I think it gives us a
more calibrated expectation for future
titles that are still in the oven so
what was the original plan for She-Hulk
and how and why did it change well from
the beginning we knew that She-Hulk was
going to be a half hour MCU legal comedy
that would break the fourth wall
consistent with the character in the
comics but because this is the MCU it
would still be an Avengers level event
after the premiere head writer Jessica
gow told variety that she originally
pitched to write the Black Widow movie
and her pitch had She-Hulk in it and
Marvel executive Brad winterbomb told
her it kind of feels like you're
pitching us a She-Hulk movie with Black
Widow in it GAO said that her pitch for
She-Hulk was pretty close to the version
of the series that we all saw Emile
Blonsky Abomination was always in her
pitch Bruce Banner was always in her
pitch she said that her original concept
skewed more heavily toward the Blonsky
trial actual trial that spanned multiple
episodes but she said that in her
writer's room none of them were adept at
writing routes in trial scenes her her
words there and you know now that the
season is done I gotta say gal
definitely sold herself short there
because the courtroom debate between
She-Hulk and Murdock was one of the best
scenes of the series it established
clear character points of view and let
both of these characters be intelligent
and Fierce and lay the groundwork for
Jen and Matt's romantic rivalry and paid
off MCU World building with Daredevil
and the sokovia courts and it
thoughtfully resurrected the superhero
privacy debate that was never settled
after Civil War we would have loved
several episodes of this and again this
series was always designed to break the
fourth wall the very first footage we
saw of She-Hulk all the way back in
November 2021 show Jen Landing in that
Burbank Sound Stage even though they
digitally removed production equipment
from the background this teaser footage
also showed her at the red carpet event
that was in the penultimate episode and
it showed her and Bruce in that parody
of the 1978 Bill Bixby Incredible Hulk
series that opened the finale so
whatever rewrites reshoots or re-edits
happened after November 2021 those
elements were all still part of the end
game for this series Jessica GAO told
the Hollywood a reporter that she
pitched at least 20 different versions
of the finale and that Kevin feige told
her that she did not have to do a big
marble ending he fully supported the
choice to introduce Kevin as a robot now
GAO did say that she and feige debated
over the exact look of the Kevin robot
gal said that she pitched and Akira
meets a HAL 9000 like AI brain slash
robot and that her script called for the
robot to be wearing a Kevin feige black
baseball cap foggy pushed back on that
asking why would a robot wear a hat and
then the viz Dev team suggested to
incorporate the ball cap into the design
of the robot Marvel concept artist Jeff
Simpson tweeted a number of alternate
designs for Kevin from something that
looked more like an old school computer
server to something more sci-fi and
matrixy more truly Akira with tendril
sneaking out of it in every direction
some of the most recognizable characters
in nerd demart bald you got Nick Fury
you got Mace Windu I guess I'm just
naming Samuel Jackson characters oh well
you get the idea Samuel Jackson makes
being bald look cool and easy but if
your hair is falling out and you don't
want it to well there are easier ways of
dealing with it than because be one of
the most iconic actors on the planet and
keeps has you covered keeps offers
clinically proven research-backed
treatments to stop hair loss and improve
hair growth two out of three guys will
experience hair loss by the time they're
35 but with peeps you can get quality
expert care without ever visiting a
doctor's office or Pharmacy all keeps
treatment plans are recommended by a
licensed medical provider and delivered
straight to your door at about half the
cost of a local pharmacy each treatment
plant comes with a full year of
unlimited messaging so you can connect
with your medical provider about
anything anytime keeps has a network of
Expert Medical advisors prescribers and
Care Specialists to support you in
making your hair goals a reality whether
you're looking to prevent hair loss
stimulate hair growth or just take
better care of the hair that you have
keep says you covered hair loss stops
with peeps to get 50 off your first
order go to keeps.com new rockstars or
click the link in the description that's
k-e-e-p-s.com Slash new rockstars now
bring in a daredevil gal said was the
result of the Riders mining the comics
for any Marvel character who ever gotten
legal trouble they actually wanted to
bring in Spider-Man of course they did
every Marvel title wants to bring
Spider-Man in thank you Spider-Man but
you shot that down gal said that they
always plan to introduce a new Cameo as
a Twist at the end and typical MCU style
and said that it was Kevin feige who
decided that that would be Hulk's son
scar concept artist Constantine sakaris
has shared several different alternate
designs for scar some with longer and
Messier hair but it seems like they went
with a design that labeled scar
Gladiator maybe with an intent to
establish Hulk's son as another
gladiator from the sakar fighting arena
either way bringing scar in here was
something that was very very important
to Kevin feige for the future of its
franchise but the problem is introducing
scar in this whole subplot of Hulk
having to leave Earth for a cigar
involves perhaps the most complex
restructuring of this series because
Jessica GAO also told variety that
originally the She-Hulk and Hulk
backstory with the car crash in the
training days in Mexico were originally
not going to be in the pilot episode
they were actually going to be revealed
in episode 8. gal said that several
factors were involved in this decision
but ultimately people wanted to know the
information sooner and it was hard for
viewers to get to know the character
without knowing her urgency story and
she added that moving scenes with two
Hulk characters earlier to episode 1 was
a big reason behind the VFX crunch
because that meant the very first
episode of the series was gonna have a
lot of VFX in it and they would have
less time to refine everything the
writers and director actually started to
get requests from the bfx team to edit
scenes in a particular way so that Jen's
Transformations would not have to be
shown on camera director Kat Coro told
the direct that this restructuring led
to the episode number of the season
going down since Marvel never really
forces these episodes to have a
particular length now the VFX side of
this is really what everyone bust over
when this came up but I think we all
missed how big a deal it is that the
original plan was to withhold Jen's
origin story with Hulk until episode 8.
that would mean everything with the Hulk
the sakar ship causing the car crash
Hulk's off-world departure in episode
two those were all going to be late in
the season questions that paid off in
the finale so this restructuring I
believe had two very challenging side
effects on the series one it resulted in
viewers becoming over invested in the
intelligency of blood-theft plot as a
real threat that we should worry about
when the writers really wanted us to see
it as a cliche Trope that they were
going to make fun of a red herring if
the original plan was to leave that
whole blood plot read dangling after
episode 7 Then followed by a really cool
flashback episode with Hulk and Mexico
and car ships and Then followed by an
even cooler Daredevil episode and then
pick up what the oh yeah the
Intelligentsia in the finale more of us
probably would have felt the forced
Whiplash of that and then joined Jen and
her mockery of this cliche and then
cheered her on as she forced Kevin to
change it but instead as presented there
wasn't a 10th episode and there really
wasn't enough of a buffer from the
intelligency developments of episode 7
so that when we headed into the finale
viewers legitimately wanted to see how
that blood plot would pay off the
writers might have actually
underestimated how Okay Marvel viewers
are with comic bookie tropes but the
second side of this was of course a
completely restructured pilot episode
which is a very big deal the pilot
episode is arguably the most important
especially when you're releasing these
episodes week by week so what was the
original pilot of She-Hulk then so so
when you subtract the elements that gal
said we're going to be in episode 8 and
then merge together episodes one and two
you actually get a pretty sturdy half
hour MCU legal action comedy Jen
prosecutes the case Jen hulks out in a
fight Titania she gets famous she gets
fired she gets hired at glkh she gets
assigned Abomination gets Bruce's
blessing followed by an Indian tying in
Abominations Cameo from Chi which would
have been a pretty mind-blowing moment
for MCU fans so really the only thing
missing in all of this some backstory
that I suspect was actually dropped the
reason they really went down from 10 to
9 episodes is why the Titania crashed
into Jen's courtroom Jen was Prosecuting
an accidental death case against a
corporation and Titania smashed in right
as she began her argument the episode 2
News Montage reports that her lawyers
claimed the incident was an unfortunate
misunderstanding the result of an
extreme case of low blood sugar
no some [ __ ] excuse from her lawyers
in tiny text on a TV screen is not
actual backstory we are clearly meant to
doubt this titanium must have had some
connection to these accidental deaths or
maybe the corporation was using her to
cause a mistrial maybe they wanted to
tie Titania into the Thunderbolts but
then later on decided they didn't really
want to do that after all and there's
just really no way to edit around in a
way that made sense whatever it was some
subplot was removed you do not introduce
the character that big and completely
whiff on her motivation in the pilot
episode so there I think was the
original plan for this series let's
summarize Jen Walters already with her
She-Hulk Powers as an attorney in the
first episode Bruce Banner and Emile
blonski Abomination also in the pilot
Abominations trial spanning several
episodes the origin story delayed to a
later episode possible Titania
thunderbolt's backstory and the
intelligencia plot a more obvious red
herring and then a finale that still
jumps into the real world to confront a
Kevin robot but one with a much scarier
design so so this Balancing Act of
creative priorities is really hard and
It's just tough to know how invested
viewers are going to get in certain
subplots and at the end of all this I'm
just super impressed that this series
was this enjoyable the truth is this
kind of creative restructuring happens
in literally every movie and TV show
it's just that we don't notice or really
care about it in other franchises the
MCU is the biggest franchise in history
it's scrutinized way more than any other
title is so we noticed these changes we
assign them greater importance when we
do but hey In fairness to us Marvel also
invites us to scrutinize with meta
Easter eggs Promises of continuity and
now characters who literally talk to us
so do you think you would have liked
this original She-Hulk plan better and
also do you like me diving deeper to
analyze story structure like this I do
have a background in screenwriting so I
just like celebrating how hard this task
is so I hope to do more of this kind of
thing if you're into it you can follow
me on Tick Tock Instagram and Twitter at
EA boss follow new rockstars And
subscribe to new rockstars for more
analysis of everything you love thanks
for watching bye
[Music]
thank you
[Music]